Let's go next to our caller from the three
one nine area code.
Who's calling today from three one nine.
Yeah.
Hey David.
My name is Phil wing and I'm a student here.
I want to state universities and I was also
a student organizer on campus, the burning.
And my question for you is, um, what do you
think about DNC potentially adding superdelegates
in the first round?
Well, I think we all know exactly why they're
thinking about it, right?
Mm, the right.
Yeah.
So for people who don't know, let me just
explain, fooling for a second.
In 2016 there were these things called super
delegates and so you know, Bernie and Hillary
would have a primary and then they'd like
split the pledge delegates, but then you would
be shown on corporate media a running total
and it would add pledged delegates to superdelegates
and it was like Hillary had already sealed
the thing.
And these are party officials and others who
in 2016 got to vote along with the pledge
delegates at the democratic national convention
to select the nominee.
It's completely anti-democratic.
So the DNC under pressure since 2016 said,
okay, we're going to give just the pledge
delegates who are earned by winning primaries,
the first round of voting without super delegates.
However, if the pledge delegates don't determine
a winner, then in the second round of voting
super delegates come in, this was considered
more democratic and probably good for an outsider
candidate like Bernie Sanders.
Now that Bernie has been surging, there are
numerous reports including in Politico that
the DNC is again thinking of could we put
super delegates back in that first round of
voting and it's very transparent that the
goal would be to deny Bernie the nomination.
Now the one thing that I did read is that
even though it's a discussion, it seems that
the DNC knows that would, it would be extremely
problematic to do it and there would be massive
blow back.
So I've read they're talking about it but
not that they're determined to do it.
Okay.
Yeah cause I was just, I was just pretty curious
about that just because like slapping and
16 and stuff like that and my now since I'm
an Iowa I was like, you know, there's been
like, it's been pretty sketchy around here,
you know, like hopes are running high and
everything like that.
And like most of the delegates, like it was
like the major hubs were Bernie won.
They still not counted yet.
So it was just like how it is.
Like how Pete was taken in the lead.
Like he came to early victory in the media,
kind of went with that.
So it's just like, it's like, I feel like
it would be a repeat of, again with be youth,
youth putting their hands where they shouldn't
be.
Yeah.
Well, you know, as, as people will be able
to tell is as of this recording, we don't
have yet, but we don't have 100% counted yet.
But, uh, that I, I don't, I, I'm not completely
sure that once we get to 100%, things are
going to drastically reverse from where they
are now.
I think we just have to wait and see.
Yeah.
Sounds good.
All right.
Well Wayne, great to hear from you.
Appreciate the phone call very, very much.